I noticed something very interesting on
the CBS Sunday morning portion of our
website Grammy Award winning singer you
know her from Greece she was sandy also
the song let's get physical' that's
Olivia newton-john she's opening up
about battling cancer for the third time
and she spoke with our Gayle King at her
California ranch about how she's dealt
with the pain how bad was the pain
really bad yeah crying kind of pain how
do you stay in the moment and stay
present and not let it consume you and
worry you okay denial he's really good
he's really healthy but it was consuming
my day and after time I went you know
what I don't know what my time is but I
had need to enjoy my life the joy of
life and everyday living has to be a
part of that healing process as well so
the reason I thought this was so
interesting is one of the ways she deals
with the pain is apparently medical
marijuana yeah another way is and then
her husband grows for her I love her
philosophy in dealing with illness she
says why me has never been part of it I
never felt victimized because it's a
decision how am I gonna deal with it you
know just cancer but you can adjust how
you respond to is that you know she
turned 71 yesterday and the cancer has
come back for a third time it's now it's
now been diagnosed as Stage four but
it's not something that consumes her
it's not something that she dwells on
she really does feel just live your life
and have a positive attitude and she
certainly has that and she looks great
you know she's doing the interview
because she's trying to raise money for
her Cancer Center so she's auctioning
off those grease plants yes Wow in the
grease jacket that we saw and can she
get in them again that is well can I
just say I like her music I do too but I
might have bought a couple of her albums
just for the covers she's a white of
influenced by